[Music] I'd like to better myself and job
because I have to live and I have to live
for six other people and I feel that if he
brought these children into the world then
you have to look at them now I'm not saying this
for anyone to feel sorry for me because these are
my children I'm responsible for and I'm very
proud of them today packed and rechecked 468
pieces and there's a lot of work to me it seemed
as though it's sort of hard to get promotion you
have to work your way up but see mike is taking
longer than a shirt and there's nothing you can
do you'll never enough money or the win is too
high and I think that it just is just scary I
would like to move because there's nothing up
room my children are growing up seven people
in one house that's really not enough room they
have time to go out on the street and play with
other children but I'd rather they didn't because
one of the reasons I'm not here and so I asked him
to stand until I get here most of the time when
I get home he's cleaned up the house is in order
my son was three years old and I have a
babysitter which she doesn't charge me
that much for babysitting because she know that I
have six children and I can't afford to pay a lot
and I might not get where I want to get soon but
I'm gonna keep on trying and I try to explain to
the children that you can't only live for today
yesterday for tomorrow too and when you encourage
yourself and your children like that one of these
days if you don't make it then one of them will
given only the chances every other
ethnic group has had sooner or later
the black ghetto will pass away it will
take the education the employment and the
enthusiasm that stoked the energies
of the other America all around it
some people say solutions to inner-city problems
are hopeless that we won't see significant changes
in our lifetime at the league we're working
to make sure there's progress get up and go
somewhere else that's an illusion inner-city
problems have a way of following the people
want to escape them in this most segregated
of northern cities it's a long way from here
to anywhere else with fixed children all you can
do is hope you know but I would like them to have
a better place to live because one thing you're
afraid to go outside there's little housing at a
price mrs. Palmer can afford now can even hope
to afford her children giving the educational
and job opportunity she never had may hope
for better if they can cope with the costs
with the zoning laws with the deliberate
exclusionary policies with the apathy in
the inertia of government on every level with
the banking policies that rule them out for
credit for mortgages for a chance to live a
little better in the richest nation on earth
[Music]